-You look great.
Great to see you.
You look stunning on the cover
of "Town & Country" here too.
Ooh la la.
-Ooh la la.
-Ooh la la, Sassoon.
-We have a lot to talk about,
because --
-Yeah, we do.
-Since the last time
you were here,
you are now engaged
and you have a baby.
-Yeah, a lot of things happened.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Oh, my God.
-I know.
-Are you freaking out?
How -- Are you loving it?
What's -- How's the baby?
-What if I was like,
"I -- I'm, like, 50/50"?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, yeah.
-No, I'm completely
obsessed with it.
I love it.
Everything's different.
Like, my Spotify is just like,
"Oh, you just want various
versions of 'Old MacDonald.'"
That seems to be --
-That was your Spotify Wrapped
for the year?
-Yeah.
And my whole phone is like,
"Oh, should we just
become your baby monitor?
Like, do you use
anything else here?"
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's everything now.
I'm obsessed with him.
We're just in love.
-How old -- How old?
-He's, like, 14 months old.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I know. I know.
-Just on --
I said, "like"
to be cool about it
because saying "14 months
old and 2 days" isn't as cool.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-And how is --
how are your parents?
How are the grandparents?
-They are obsessed.
They are completely enamored.
And they're also the greatest.
-They live to close
to you, right?
-Very, very close.
They stop by a lot.
-They do?
-Yeah, a lot.
No, in a good way.
Sorry.
-No, no, no.
-I realize, like, I'm --
-No, we didn't sense
any sarcasm there.
-No, no. A lot.
-No, yeah, of course.
You love it.
-It's, like,
they are wonderful.
-Of course, they are.
-I'm really lucky.
-They're the best.
-You are being sarcastic.
-[ Laughs ] Am I?
-"They're the best."
-"Who knows?"
-"Who doesn't love
when parents stop by?"
-"I love when parents come by."
-"I love an unannounced
stop by."
-"I, one day, surprise me."
Yeah, of course.
But is your dad --
he must be all over it.
-Oh, yeah. He's so into it.
And also, like --
So the biggest mystery --
It's the first grandchild,
and so the big question was,
like, "What are the names?"
And so my parents were going for
Jay-Jay and Bub.
That was the goal.
My dad was gonna be Bub.
But because my dad
is a little bit of a ham,
as you may know...
-Is he?
-Yes, slightly.
And making a baby laugh
is, like,
one of the greatest achievements
one can have in the world.
-I agree.
-For some reason, every time
he saw our baby, he would say --
he would quote
the great Jerry Lewis,
who you know as well.
And he'd say, "Hey, lady."
But do you mind performing it
the way Jerry Lewis used to?
-[ As Jerry Lewis ] Hey, lady!
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
So -- And, like --
There's no, like,
logical reason.
-I love it!
-There's, like, a tiny baby
who's, like,
cute and cuddly and small
and, like, just learning how
to move and blink and stuff,
and my dad's walking into
a quiet room and just going...
-Hey, lady! Hey!
Hey, lady!
-Exactly. Exactly.
-[ Normal ] Oh, my Gosh.
That's fantastic.
-His whole life,
every time he comes in,
that's what he says.
Cut to now, guess what our son
is calling my dad?
-Lady?
-[ Chuckling ] Yes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That's fantastic.
You can't plan those things.
-No. You can't plan it.
So the big question is, like,
do we keep referring to him
as Bub,
or do we just go with it
and say, "Lady's here"?
-"Lady's here."
I love it so much.
-Yeah.
-Give him my best, please.
I miss him. I love him.
Let's talk about "M3gan."
'Cause, by the way --
-Let's talk about it.
-I cannot wait for this.
It is the freakiest, scariest
thing ever in the world.
It's getting great reviews,
by the way.
95% Fresh on Rotten Tomatoes.
-Fresh.
-Fresh. Yes.
-You star in it.
You also executive produced it.
Can you set up what "M3gan"
is for everyone?
-So, basically, it is
the story of a -- an A.I. robot
that has been designed
to look like a doll
and is an ideal playmate
for a kid
and kind of, like,
a nanny/co-parent to a parent.
-Yeah.
-And my character, Gemma,
is the roboticist who is --
who has designed her.
And I get custody of my niece
under very tragic circumstances.
And so, I think, "I don't know
what to do with a kid.
I know what I'll do.
I'll use this robot
I've been working on
and use it to help me
raise my niece
who I don't know how to handle.
And I'll put them together
because the robot
needs the little girl
to grow and learn.
And the little girl
needs a robot to, like,
be sad about these
terrible things
that have happened to her."
-Oh, my gosh.
-And, you know,
it just all goes really well.
-Yeah, of course.
Is that right? Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
Everything's fine.
And it's a 20-minute movie.
-And Jason Blum?
-Yeah, Jason Blum, James Wan.
We've got some, like,
horror royalty here.
Did you work with them
on "Get Out"?
-I worked with Jason Blum on
"Get Out," yeah.
-Whoo-hoo!
-And so did he say hey --
-Yeah. Oh, thank you!
-Yeah, of course.
-Thank you.
-And was he like,
"Hey, I have the next project
for you"?
-Yeah, he literally e-mailed me,
and it was like a bat signal
kind of an e-mail --
one of those things
you can't really turn down,
even though I didn't want to.
He was like, "We need you."
And I was like, "Oh, God.
Okay."
What am I --
-Yeah.
-What do you need, another,
like, evil white girl?
And he was like, "Kind of."
[ Laughter ]
Sort of. I have a niche.
What can I say?
-Yeah! Stereotype, of course.
-Yeah, so then I was like --
I didn't know anything else
about the script,
so I just went into it knowing
just that Jason
thought I would do well in it.
And so I started reading,
and then I was hooked.
It's just one of those things
that is riveting.
You don't know
where it's gonna go.
I mean, once you meet the doll,
you're like,
"I don't think I'm gonna be
rooting for this doll
the whole time."
But in this movie,
you do root for her
and you're not expecting to.
Like, she does
some dastardly deeds,
and you're still cheering
for her to do them,
which is messed up.
-When did you first
see the doll?
-I first saw the --
I saw a bunch
of digital renderings.
But the first time
I actually met the doll,
she was doing a camera test.
And -- Which means that
before you start
filming to test the lenses
and everything in wardrobe,
you just go into an empty
soundstage with a backdrop.
Kind of, like, over there.
And she was just
standing there like this.
And people were, like, touching
up her hair and stuff like that.
And I just thought,
"This is gonna be
the scariest experience
of my life."
-What you just did was scary.
-Yeah, just --
-Yeah, and that was --
-And someone's just
combing her hair.
And then -- Ooh.
So, one of the versions
of her --
We achieved her in a bunch
of different ways --
but one of them was animatronic.
And because she blinks, her eyes
get stuck sometimes,
so, they have to, like, put --
[ Laughter ]
-One -- one lid.
-Listen, it's not --
Who says my job is easy?
-No.
-You have to look --
So, there's someone
putting a lubricant
on her eyeball.
And I'm like, "She --
I know she's not real.
I know she's not real."
But she is talking and blinking
and her face is moving.
-Yeah.
-And you're putting something
on her eyeball
and it just looks weird.
-I want to show everyone what
M3gan the doll looks like.
-Here's our girl.
-There she is.
[ Audience murmurs ]
-Cutie.
-Yeah, cute.
-Now, that was a real range
of expressions.
-Yeah, emotions.
Yeah. It was a roller coaster.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Allison Williams
in "M3gan."
Take a look at this.
-I thought I heard something.
It sounded like M3gan.
-If she comes in this room,
I'll rip your head off right off
your neck, I swear to God.
-I thought about what you said,
about how when
something's broken,
you don't just throw it away.
You fix it.
So, that's what
I'm trying to do.
But don't come in here, Cady,
it's kind of a mess.
-Aunt Gemma's right, Cady.
I'm all odds and ends right now.
I'd really rather you didn't
see me like this.
-[ Gasps ]
-It sounds like
you're fighting.
-Both: We're not fighting.
-Gemma just dropped me
on the table, but I'm okay.
Clumsy Gemma.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What?!
"Clumsy Gemma."
-"Clumsy Gemma."
-Ohh.
-Your whole physical reaction
should just be the only ad
campaign we do for this movie.
-That's really what I felt.
-Whatever you just did.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it --
when the trailer came out,
it went viral immediately,
and people were freaking out.
People were dressed like M3gan
for Halloween.
-Before it even came out?
-Movie's not even out yet.
-When we were designing her,
we were like,
I mean, ideally, it's a costume
that becomes iconic
and people will dress up
like her for Halloween.
And it's like a cult costume
that you can identify.
And then last Halloween,
people were doing it.
We were so excited.
It was the greatest.
There's a scene where, it went
viral, of -- M3gan is dancing.
-Yes.
-Down a hallway.
We have that moment.
Check this out.
♪♪
-Yeah, yeah. So, that --
[ Audience murmurs ]
That went viral. People were
posting their own versions of --
-Yep. They were setting it
to different songs.
They were doing
their own versions of it.
People were cartwheeling
into things.
It was the greatest.
-Yeah.
You guys saw that, right?
Did everyone see that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience cheers ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
Allison Williams, everyone!
"M3gan" is in theaters now.
Allison and I are playing
the "Singing Whisper Challenge"
when we come back.
Stick around.
Oh!
♪♪